a dishwasher squasher President Biden
once again inviting himself into your
house and he's got a new rule that will
dramatically cut water use per cycle in
dishwashers alright so Harold it's
something like the dishwashers 30 less
power uh so the upside is the food
that's stuck to your plate will be
squeaky clean and edible
if this is going to make things better
and safer and more efficient and it
still cleans our dishes I'm forward my
daughter is a big big proponent of us
using less water in our household so I'm
not gonna oh well then maybe she should
run for governor
president
it just occurred to me that liberals
want to get rid of mechanical
dishwashers and return to the humankind
hence their Embrace for cheap illegal
labor who needs a who needs to buy a
Westinghouse when you can get somebody
from I don't know Colombia it's true
Venezuela Venezuela that's what it is
it's true you've hit upon it do you
remember when President Trump talked
about this yeah it was like one of the
most bipartisan things he ever said
because everyone agrees there's not
enough power in the dishwasher and
there's no reason a dishwasher should
have to run for two and a half hours and
then if you have to run it twice because
your dishes aren't clean that's five
hours and then your electricity bills
goes up as does your electric stove
electricity bill so they're just going
round and round and biting themselves in
the butt oh watch your mouth Jesse have
you ever ever watched a single dish of
course I have do you even know what a
kitchen looks like I haven't watched
this well I'm a big proponent of soaking
soaking doesn't work you know if it's
like a messy pot you just put some soap
in there hot water and then leave it for
your wife to handle that is disgusting
but I learned something the last time we
talked about this is that you're
supposed to have a little food on the
plate when you put it in the dishwasher
because the soap from the dishwasher
reacts to the food and cleans the dish
more effectively yeah that's how I'll do
that one of the other co-hosts on a
Friday when you were here
and that's why you're not supposed to
get all the little food particles off
Yeah by hand before you put it in you're
supposed to put it in dirty judge
you want to hear that
let's work here's a bottom line they're
going to reduce the performance it's
going to cost you more money then what
it's not going to be as clean then
you're going to have to wash it anyway
they say you have to use reduce water by
30 so now you have to keep washing it
when it comes out I don't want to wash
it a second time wash it the solution
paper plates
and then they're going to have and then
what they're going to do is because it's
going to cost more they're going to move
the factories out of the country and
make them somewhere else so the only
people who lose are the wives and the
women and it's not right yeah I clean in
my house but what if they can make them
stronger like this this phone no energy
they have less energy
much smaller these things are and how
much more powerful if the iPhone can
clean the dishes that'd be great yes
there you go hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else